joining us now is Florida congressman
Matt Gaetz American Conservative Union
Chairman match slap and civil rights in
criminal defense attorney David showing
or a good evening gentlemen congressman
gates I'm going to start with you
you know underlying all of this and the
reason we're here is because we're
finally getting the opportunity to see
some of the documents some of the text
messages some of the emails and yet here
we are in the middle of the summer and
we still don't have all of those
requested documents from the DOJ and the
FBI what makes you guys think that
struck is going to tell you anything and
not claim the fifth it's not the answers
he gives it's the ones he doesn't that
seem to interest me the most I'm
particularly interested in Peter strux
interactions with Robert Muller after
Muller found out about these text
messages and I think we'll learn a lot
about the lack of curiosity that Muller
had in determining whether or not the
bias of Peter struck you know actually
manifested in the official actions of
the investigation now Peter struck at
one point was America's top spy catcher
so don't expect him to crawl into the
fetal position and begin weeping you
know he will have his side of the story
I think largely he was dishonest and and
very opaque and his answers in his
closed-door session okay in that slap I
mean one of the things that that you've
been talking about is the fact that the
Republicans haven't seemed to learn to
step up and stand up for the President
and for the party at large and just kind
of live and let live I think we've
really had a failure to understand
Republicans in Congress have had a
failure to understand that oversight is
one of the most critical things that
they have to do constitutionally they
have the power of the purse they fund
these agencies it's their job to make
sure the money is being spent well judge
what we have seen with the abuses at the
FBI make none of us happy because all of
us respect the FBI we do we need the FBI
but it's because we respect the FBI when
we see this type of wrongdoing
we have to stand up and say enough but
as citizens we're not empowered to do
much it's Congress that's empowered to
do what needs to be done and I tell you
the Republicans in Congress is a real
bone
for them they have to demonstrate to the
countries it has this had nothing to do
with our national security in Russia it
has everything to do with never Trump
errs embedded at the top spots of the
FBI and trying to impact that election
saying they will stop Donald Trump if
that is not enough for Republicans in
Congress to say that they will take all
the appropriate steps to end it and DOJ
has to do the same they're not doing it
you know what I'm asking them to do it
to tell ya finding out you know what are
you gonna do what are you gonna hold him
in contempt what are you gonna damage
shown now you know the system better
than anyone all right you say that when
struck testified behind closed doors
there should have been some
preconditions what were they absolutely
first of all we know from the inspector
general that we don't have a whole set
of struck or pages emails we should have
all of those Congress must demand that
they be produced Judicial Watch is on to
those kinds of things but it's not again
it's not just struck remember what we
didn't see and that an inspector general
report was anyone at any point ever
telling struck or his colleagues that
their conduct was inappropriate what I
really want to see them get to is this
meeting that struck told the IG about
that he had with page and with Andrew
McCabe in McCabe's office during which
the agenda was stopped Trump McCabe
denies it or he doesn't recall it I want
to get to the bottom of that so how do
we how do we get to the bottom of it
well first of all remember
strux attorney has been boasting that
struck is dying to testify openly at
Congress that he will testify that he's
an unfair victim here one thing we know
for sure is that there is no good answer
to the emails that struck wrote he's
gonna have to eat those and that sets
the agenda and remember that infected
the whole process you know the IG found
he can't determine whether bias infected
the prosecutorial decisions but remember
the prosecutor is only as good as the
investigator he or she makes his or her
decisions on whether to prosecute based
on the body of investigative material
they're given so people like struck
decided what to go after what not to go
after etcetera thoroughness in a central
position and
when gates you know the frustration that
I have in the viewers have is that you
know there are some guys like you you
know whether in Jim Jordan and Ron de
santis and and trey Gowdy most of the
time but we're not seeing a lot of
action here what can we expect as
opposed to just saying bring him in well
to my friend match lap I would I would
point him to the comments of rod Rosen
Stein on May 1st when he said that
Congress has no constitutional role for
oversight that's what we're fighting
against Department of Justice that
doesn't believe we have a right for
oversight it's outrageous and frankly it
shows how important it is for the small
group of us who've been really pounding
the facts on this issue to get support
from our leadership you know how the
Democrats will do oversight judge
Jeanine they'll say the damn documents
will be there at 10 o'clock or your
impeachment proceeding begins at 10:01
that's what we ought to do we ought to
demand the documents or we ought to
begin impeachment proceedings gates it's
the leadership are we talking about Paul
Ryan or we're talking about good lad
we're talking about Mitch McConnell
let's name them because this is what the
viewers and what the American people
want you can come on and talk all you
want for the next 30 minutes the next 30
days if the leadership doesn't let you
do it then you can't do it
am I right or wrong congressman you're
right I have been in Congress for about
18 months judge Jeanine and I haven't
entirely figured out this place yet but
I know that nothing happens unless the
leadership wants it to happen I am proud
of Judiciary Chairman Bob Goodlatte for
accelerating the schedule I think we're
gonna have to Comey and Lynch and struck
and page all giving public testimony
very soon and I'm encouraged by that but
from the speaker's office on down we
need more support those of us who need
the documents than who want to hold open
hearings of the American I'll go to
Matt's lap what kind of support is he
talking about I don't need someone's
permission to ask for a document we've
got civil attorneys about tom Fitton
going to court and getting it on his own
congress is that impotent yeah I mean
that's exactly right what the
congressman just said is they can demand
it they can hold someone in contempt and
they can start impeachment proceedings
but the key is is this which is the end
of the day judge it's a political
question and the American people are
watching and if these congressmen
Republicans don't take these aggressive
steps they're gonna throw people out of
office and there's a leadership race for
the house for the to be the next speaker
on the Republican side hopefully we hold
on to that majority I think I think
these types of decisions will impact
that race and finally the tij is going
to have to prosecute they don't
prosecute there none of this events
anything well and I agree David don't
chew I mean it seems that and I think at
one point trey gowdy may have said
something like that you know I'm more
interested in finding out the truth and
you know the criminal consequences well
I'm a prosecutor I'm interested in
criminal consequences I'm interested in
setting the record I'm interested in
making a precedent for this if you are
at the upper echelon of the chief law
enforcement agency in the nation and it
seems the whole top echelon was going in
one direction for Hillary against Trump
then I have to believe the whole culture
of the FBI other than the regular guys
in the field offices there's a problem
look it clearly reflects the culture let
me say this my father was an FBI agent I
grew up an FBI groupie this is a huge
blemish on the FBI but it is a culture
and it also infects the prosecutors let
me tell you this judge this is one of
the worst cases in the FBI but I have
the worst case of FBI corruption in the
Eastern District of New York and you
know the prosecutor was on that case
Andrew Weissman yeah the right-hand man
of Muller so we'd say culture here yes
and the America it shouldn't be a left
or right issue the American people that
was disappointing here for someone not
politically sophisticated the American
people should demand transparency
there's not an investigation in which a
source would be busted here a real
national security consequence if we
expose as information listen the
presiding judge of the FISA Court judge
Collier told Congress that they should
ask the Justice Department for the FISA
application documents now look I think
the judge also should exercise her
supervisory capacity given the
wrongdoing we know with those
applications the misleading and the
omissions all right your signature comes
down to and I'll go to you congressman
and we only a few seconds left it comes
down to a prosecutor I don't need to
hear about this in it with all due
respect to you congressman I don't need
to hear about this in an open session I
don't need to read all these emails I
need a real
prosecutor - get in there and find out
what the truth is and whether or not
everything they said and did which
indicates a negative intent or trouble
is is acted upon and Ron Rosen signs not
going to do it and Jeff Sessions isn't
gonna do it so is there justice
congressman gates in this in the end I
don't think there will be if Jeff
Sessions remains the Attorney General
and it is a sad thing to have to admit
that judge Jeanine but we have demanded
a special prosecutor to make precisely
the decisions that you just outlined and
Jeff Sessions has proven to be very
captive to the deep state actors at the
Department of Justice that seem to have
him very flummoxed all right last words
match slap I'm more hopeful I actually
think the American people are appalled
at this and I actually think there are
thousands of prosecutors at DOJ and I
think they're gonna demand that
something be done if nobody is sitting
in jail after this all happens there's
going to be a political revolt like we
haven't seen for a long time but there's
no prosecutor who can do it without rod
Rosenstein who convinced jeff Sessions
to recuse himself who doesn't have the
political will of be polite sandai
doesn't have the political will to go in
there and put together a grand jury
well maybe there'll be some changes
maybe there'll be some changes though
yeah you're right judge and you know
about prosecutors you know that
prosecutors look it has to change from
the top I don't say the president should
have to be the bad guy but there
shouldn't even be this crisis with
Congress and contempt rod Rosenstein has
to be removed look he's running the
Muller investigation we know how broad
that has gone now and he got cute with
Jim Jordan the other day when he was
asked who told struck he couldn't answer
these questions he said look you know
I've got 150 15,000 employees I don't
know he's just one that's nonsense the
focus is on struck and the FBI director
and everyone else ought to be mortified
at what has been uncovered now smart guy
David shown gentlemen Congressman Matt
Gaetz said Matt slap great great segment